joining us right now from espn the uh
man who covers the green bay packers for
espn nfl nation is rob dymovsky here on
the rich eisen show calling in
from wisconsin how are you rob i'm doing
well rich how are you
i am doing fine all right i'm i'm
turning to you for my interpreter
you speak fluent rogers um so
interpret what he said on sportscenter
monday night and his farewell
um to kenny mayne appearance what do you
got for me
it's a language that i have been
studying for 16 years now and i feel
like i am somewhat fluent in it and with
all things rogers it's not necessarily
what he says it's what he doesn't say
and who didn't he
say that he loves in that that clip
right he he said he loved the fans he
loved the
coaches he loves his teammates i never
heard the words brian gudekunst or mark
murphy that would be the general manager
and the president of the packers and
when he thinks talked about
doing things the right way you have to
read in that that he believes that those
two people did not do things the right
way
when it came to treating him and this
goes back to obviously the jordan love
pick nothing personal to love
but we know that brian gooda koontz
never gave rogers
the heads up that that not only might
they be picking a quarterback but that
they would trade up
in the first round to do so so let's dig
in a little bit here because i think he
said the word people
um more than a dozen times last night
and is he referring to himself as the
people of the organization or are there
others
in the organization that he knows that
he feels have been slighted and he's
taking up
for a larger cause or is this just about
what's going on with him
i think it's more what's going on with
him um and you're right i think it was
14
times our kevin seifert the crack
national reporter
uh must have time on his hands because i
saw him tweet that it was 14 times
use the word people but i would say this
um
you know this is a selfish business and
that's not a criticism
of rogers that's not a criticism of any
player
but players are selfish they want to be
treated the way that they
deserve and think that they are to be
treated i'm sitting
you know outside of lambeau field right
now and you look at this monster stadium
and and i guarantee you brett favre
probably feels like
hey if it wasn't for me they wouldn't
have been able to renovate that stadium
in 2001 and 2002. and then to the
to the west of the stadium is this
massive title town district and when
aaron rodgers drives in from his house
uh in green bay that's what he sees and
he probably says to himself
they wouldn't have built this if it
wasn't for me i made all these people
rich and i made this organization
successful and in
some ways they're right without those
two guys
green bay isn't what it is right now and
this stadium isn't one of the true gems
in
the nfl and this town isn't built up as
a tourist attraction if those guys
don't do what they did so there is some
entitlement that
maybe is deserved rob domovsky packers
reporter
been covering the team since 1997 now
with the worldwide leader in sports kind
enough to call in today
as there is the ota on field practice
for a second straight day in rogers
it was funny he confirmed he's not there
as he's sitting on
on his phone uh you know zooming in from
from hawaii for
for kenny and you know let's talk about
what we can take out of this what we can
confirm
about what we assume this whole
kerfuffle has been about based on what
that one portion of the interview where
they you know he did as
allow something to be said on it it was
funny because kenny pushed back at one
point asked him are you demanding a
trade and he said i've said all i wanted
to say let's talk about you right now
exactly so you picked up on that also so
what can we confirm because he said it
wasn't about the draft pick
and as i said at the top of the show rob
these are not mutually exclusive things
he can still love jordan love we had
aaron jones on the show talked about how
he's seen him personally uh mentor coach
up
uh jordan love so you can love the kid
but me
doesn't love the fact that the kid was
brought in in the manner in which he was
brought in
right so can we confirm that this is
about the draft pick this is what it was
about or there's something else kumaro
i mean you hear all this stuff what can
we glean from last night
here's what it comes down to rich is
that rogers thinks
that he has earned the right to control
when things
end in green bay uh and now
the the decision the pick love to trade
up to do it um
as he said shortly after it happened
made it probably not a reality that he
could control the way things end and
when he went out you know he was a good
soldier all last year right it was this
um you know he he had this sort of uh
whatever will be will be mentality
uh all the while he was marching his way
to his third mvp
and i think once he sort of proved to
everybody that you know what i am still
the best or one of the best in the game
and and yes
in 2018 you know under mike mccarthy my
last year i wasn't all that engaged and
in 2019
i was learning a new system but now with
matt lafleur's system you know
completely under his belt
he went out and and played like an mvp
that he was and now he probably feels
like he's got
the control back in his corner right so
i think that's what it's about it's
about not wanting to be a lame duck
quarterback they would
commit to him initially this this
offseason
beyond this year and he didn't want to
be a lame duck guy going into 2021
with the possibility that they were
going to move on to jordan love in 2022
and to me
all that other stuff is minor in
comparison to
to that fact that he no longer felt like
he had control over his own future
and that he felt like he deserved
control over that future so then let's
use the
the phrase that kenny did in the
interview last night about what's still
left on the table that could be cleared
off and then let's
focus on the table so uh it is a
long-term
commitment uh contract that by the
the terms and dollars precludes jordan
love from getting on the field
in time for the packers to make a
decision on whether he's worthy of a
fifth year
option pick up after year three is that
what would fix what's wrong with the
organization with people
or is it something bigger yeah it would
have
you know in january when this came about
and they and they initially balked at
that they did not
they were only offered um from what
we've reported they've only offered a
minor restructure at that point
which further sent rogers you know down
this rabbit hole
and and then by the time that they got
around offering him
the lucrative deal that would both uh
you know
take care of him uh financially but also
ensure that they were committed to him
uh for for more than just 2021 by that
time he said no
so we're at the point now where
i'm not sure what fixes this maybe
there's two things rich maybe it's
that you know public sentiment which is
already somewhat against him
in green bay uh maybe you know he is
concerned about his legacy that's
important to him maybe he gets the win
that
people will turn and have turned against
him maybe that could bring him back or
two maybe it's pressure from his
teammates saying hey we all restructured
our deals there were six or eight guys
that that restructured their deals
to make another run at it in 2021 so
they could keep this team together
you know does there come a point where
those guys say
we did this now now you got to come and
help us do what we did
what we want to do uh to get us back to
a super bowl and maybe there's pressure
from
the teammates we haven't seen that yet
but at what point do
you know i don't want to say do they
turn on him rich but at some point
uh does that happen and that that his
teammates start to
say hey we're here trying to get it done
why aren't you here with us
so you're saying rob domovsky that part
of what can get rogers to stay in green
bay is if
fans start talking to rogers
in the same way that kenny signed off on
him
last night yes that would be uh that
would help
uh you know the interesting contrast
real quick is when farv wanted to come
back
uh in 2008 he unretired the fan
sentiment was so behind brett right
and it was because he wanted to be here
the fact that rogers
doesn't want to be here has has had the
opposite effect i think
and has turned some fans not saying all
but some against him
i mean that's that's that's pretty darn
quick too rob i mean like you know
there has been 16 years built up here
and and
and and he does have the right to figure
out his own end game
in the place that he's built his home
for 16 years
and there should be a consequence upon
the general manager
who doesn't call him to let him know hey
heads up the words that's going to come
out of roger goodell's mouth are going
to piss you off
and hey you know when it's all over
after you do take us to the nfc
championship game at home
mind you we're not going to commit
longer than just this year and
you know he's smart enough to read the
writing on the wall and do the math and
knowing he's
managed i mean what do you expect out of
that guy
you know no question and it was a huge
mistake by management um
you know last april to not communicate
with them and
whatever excuse you can have oh it was a
virtual draft or things changed quickly
um you know it was it was in the end
that will end up being
uh maybe the mistake that you know ends
his time here
so then let's talk about the here and
now before i let you go rob
is that there is an ota that's going on
you mentioned before
that maybe some teammates might say hey
you know where are you i'm imagining
this is way too
early for that there is a mandatory ota
that's coming
up in june walk me through what you
expect today
uh when the coach is meeting i imagine
with the media and and what what you
expect
uh over the next couple weeks then after
practice will hear from matt leflore and
three players adrian amos kenny clark
and aaron jones noticeably absent on
that list is of course jordan love who
we'd all like to hear from
uh but we will all be watching uh jordan
love and every
open opportunity uh you know this year
because look
they have to prepare him now and matt
leflore told us this a couple weeks ago
they have to prepare
uh jordan love like he's the starter and
not just because of what aaron rodgers
is up against but because that's the job
of backup
and he's the uh he goes from third
string last year to second string
this year um but it'll be very
interesting to see what reaction
if eddie uh his coach and his teammates
have to
what roger said last night on
sportscenter with kenny may that's to me
uh i guess what i'm looking for most you
know one watching jordan love
and two hearing how guys react to what
roger said
you think you know because you know
aaron is very um smart
and wise and um also
uh savvy you know obviously wanted to
say farewell to his friend but
do you think the fact that kenny said
hey how about the day before the coach
speaks at otas
that's when you come on you know like
that that appealed to aaron
from hawaii do you think in a way timing
is everything in this business isn't it
well and i guess the last one for you is
jordan love i mean i i
when i did have aaron jones on the show
a couple weeks ago i asked him like
what about this kid you know and and
again he said that he's
uh a good teammate and a good person and
who aaron jones is as well
and and that rogers he sees him coaching
him up i mean
what this can't be like this can't be
like let's trade up to draft a kid
yeah he doesn't dress at all and then
all that's addressed of him
is the guy we've pissed off to put
rogers in the role of farv
and this kid in the role of rogers it's
crazy yeah
what is going on with him the one thing
i will say about rogers is unlike
remember when farve said it doesn't say
anywhere in my contract that i
have to mentor aaron rodgers well george
jordan love did not get that treatment
from rogers rogers uh you know
definitely was good to him from what we
could see
um it's a hard spot the two people i
think that are in the most difficult
position here
are matt lafleur because he wants to win
right and he knows his best chance to
win
is with aaron rodgers right and jordan
love is the other guy in
the most difficult spot uh because their
plan rich was to bring him along slowly
and not play in 2021 he would be the
third stringer as a rookie which he was
um and then he would be the backup this
year and was going to be
a slow education and now
that education is massively accelerated
combined with the fact that
there were no preseason games last year
training camp was
incredibly short there were no on-field
workouts so it's almost like
when they showed up yesterday for otas
it was almost like jordan love
was a rookie going through all this for
the first time because quite frankly he
didn't go through any of this
last year so it's probably another
reason that they brought blake bortles
in
to help you know jordan love and don't
forget like i mean just because rogers
if he doesn't show up and isn't the
quarterback for
whether he retires is traded whatever uh
it doesn't necessarily mean love is the
guy blake bortles is here for a reason
well and i guess there's the other one
who's in the tough spot and that's
gudekunst obviously you mentioned rob
the two that are on the field
i mean i i imagine he has no intention
of trading rogers and is going to try
and play this thing out
because i imagine there is no sense at
all from mark murphy that
maybe getting rid of guru kunst will
actually fix this like they they will
choose the organization over
rogers if that comes down to it right
yes and i said this on get up this
morning from what i was told
murphy within the organization has you
know reaffirmed the fact that gouda
kunst is staying he is the general
manager
and that no matter what is not going to
change and of course that would piss off
rogers as he drives in and sees
title town that uh general managers
don't build title towns
i do occasionally rich drive by rogers
house on the west side of green bay just
to make sure there's not a for sale sign
and i can tell you this that i did drive
by yesterday because it's right near the
gym where my kids
uh aau basketball team practices so i go
by there like twice a week
and every day i look to my left as i
pass it and there's not a for sale
signing okay
yeah and it looks lived in still right i
mean it's not the is the
the lawn is taken care of at least i'm
sure well it's gated and the fence has a
tarp on it so i really can't quite do
that okay
all right and i'll let you know if i if
i see a uh
century 21 or whatever sign up in front
of me
rob i appreciate the time look for my
call we'll we'll keep chatting i really
appreciate it rob thank you all right
thanks richard that's rob demofsky
calling in from green bay wisconsin
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here